[Music]
what's the Pookie myth as a matter of
fact that was little-known fact about me
I hate scary movies so I am very glad I
wasn't even born yet when the first
Halloween hit theaters but Jamie Lee
Curtis is not afraid to revisit the past
the original scream queen is starring in
a new installment in honor of the 40th
anniversary and Michelle Turner was
first on set and tonight we have a look
at the first scene that I pray every
night that he would escape I'm gonna be
sixty years old in November I'm standing
on the movie set of a movie I made 40
years ago
[Music]
he's back and so is he it's been four
decades since the Duggal mass murderer
Michael Myers first terrorized her in
the original Halloween in the new film
Myers is on another murder spree but
this time Jamie Lee's character of Rory
is ready for him
Jamie Lee started previous Halloween
sequels where it was revealed that she
and Michael Myers were brother and
sister but this is a true reboot and
those other storylines have been wiped
out the 1978 lorry was meek but she's
kind of a superhero this time nowadays
we have wonder women even Linda Hamilton
and Terminator you're gonna see me in a
tank top in this movie I will not have
her arms just letting in are now you
think you're gonna be like a
side-by-side of me and Linda Hamilton
I'm happen
you don't believe in okay man
do you embrace that moniker of the
ultimate scream queen every text or
comment somebody would do on social
media they go yes Queen so I you know at
some point I need to do that for me yes
get that little crown emoji pop it on
your text Jamie interesting no the
script of this movie is in good hands
because John Carpenter helped write it
now he co-wrote and directed the
original he also composed that classic
oh so creepy theme music